hey i'm laura whitmore and this is my
glamifesto for life
[Music]
my daily mantra is and i'm robbing this
um because it's a song
it's no one can change your life except
for you i love it so much so that i
actually called my book
that title my instant mood booster is
just a song that takes you back to a
certain time
of your life it could be anything from
abba or
fleetwood mac everywhere and they just
as soon as i put that song on even if
i'm in a bad
mood they all make me feel great post
the pandemic
i am most looking forward to travel
i cannot wait just to get back on a
plane or on a boat
or a train or even a long walk because
something just gets me traveling and
moving again
the best thing that i've learned in the
past year it's okay to be in the present
you know when we first got told it was
locked out it was three weeks then it
was another three weeks and
it was very hard to plan i plan ahead
and i'm someone who's always you know
what's the next thing i'm doing what's
the next thing i'm doing it was really
good for me actually to kind of
be still even if it was against my will
and
yeah just to be a little bit more
present and hopefully that's something
i'll
take with me going forward what makes me
feel passionate i get
very passionate when i see injustices
and
and things which i just think just
aren't fair and especially things i
think to do with women
and as a female who was raised by a
single mother
i was very lucky and not all you know
women in that situation can be as lucky
so making smart financial decisions um
easier said than done label i have um
have done this survey recently just
talking looking at women and
and you know when it comes to speaking
about
finances and their finances and uh
according to this research amongst these
women under 40 that most of us
and we rather talk about some
embarrassing medical ailment or we'll
talk about
men or women or relationships
but we won't talk about finances and i
don't know is there because there's a
shame around it
i think it's really important that we
are able to talk about it because
we say money doesn't isn't the number
one priority but it does
give you privileges and and
it's very important that you have a
little bit of backing
who or what can i not live without it's
quite hard because i'm like do i pick a
person or do i pick my phone
like i'm gonna say like obviously my
family and my
my partner is brilliant but like you
know what my phone is very handy as well
glamour means confidence i always think
you look your best when you feel your
best
and i think that comes hand in hand with
confidence i feel most glam
when i feel confident sometimes i could
be the baftas or the brits
and dressed up to the nines but i feel
more glamorous
down the pub with my mates my one little
thing my one little beauty
hack it's just red lipstick my biggest
achievement
is squeezing a baby out of my vagina
[Music]
i think the best way to clap back
against misogyny is to speak up about it
women are kind of put against each other
and i've spoken about this before like
when i first started
on television it's like who wore it best
or you know who do you want to be like
and
people should be against each other
while i think when women get together
they can do wonderful things the
quirkiest thing i've done many things
i just think it's good to be silly i
think sometimes we're told to
to be a bit too serious and that's
frowned upon
i'm always i'm really jealous of kids
because i feel no
kids play and they run so fast that they
fall over
i think i miss that what do i want my
legacy to be
smiling at someone like do you can do
the smallest things in life and it can
make such
a big impact dvs the designer
and was saying that we all have magic
wands
and and it's you know depending on what
we do whatever job you have or
wherever you are and being able to use
it and it's like a little bit of a magic
wand a little bit of a platform you have
to help something else
or talk about a social issue because
you've got a bit of a platform that i've
made someone
happy that is a huge legacy